what's up taste buddies i am hitting the
road to do stand-up comedy finally i
haven't been out in a while all tickets
available at
savilecanocomedy.com right now i will be
in
uh fort lauderdale to dania uh improv uh
november 12th through the 14th i will be
in the west palm beach improv uh
december 4th and 5th i will be
uh at in boston in medford at the cheval
year i don't know if i'm saying that
right theater december 10th boston come
out you always come out big and then i'm
really excited about this one the
borgata in atlantic city new jersey i
performed there like so many times with
the guys never solo first one that's
gonna be a lot of fun uh where else we
going with this the week between
christmas and new year's eve december 26
dallas december 27 san antonio december
28th sugarland december 29th st louis
missouri december 30th column columbus
ohio and new year's eve in cincinnati
ohio all co-headlining with chrissy d
all tickets savile kennel comedy.com
right now
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking taste buds hi taste buddies
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds our third fall start of
today true third time starting the
podcast but here we are we're off and
running and we got a candy powerhouse
battle for you we got the next two eps
uh today's october 25th and next week
will be november 1st we're doing two
this is a halloween adjacent yes the way
we worded it was which halloween candy
would you prefer dropped in your bag
peanut m ms
or peanut butter cups reese's peanut
butter cups correct and since we did
snickers and kitkat and that trended we
thought nothing would take down snickers
and kitkat did so we're doing two more
powerhouse today yes and uh these are
big ones these are biggins and i don't
know who's gonna win him and uh we were
talking about maybe on the heels of that
doing a full-on candy tournament one day
we've talked about it we've talked about
doing uh themed we should do tournaments
of all tournaments uh you know it's
tough because it's tough to find
enough battles to last through the month
that are that that you feel strongly
about that fit the tournament all that
but what i do think we could do at that
worst case scenario is a power another
lightning round up like for thanksgiving
say that we've discussed like battle of
the sides where it's three sides battles
uh that's not a tournament though
well i'm saying i'm saying worst case
scenario like a sweet 16 babe i know but
i'm saying like a hateful eight so i
hear you but you know you try filling
that with all these similar foods and or
whatevers yeah and finding enough that
you care about that's that's a tough
film maybe thanksgiving size isn't the
right thing for a tournament i think
that's what we're netting out i mean you
know i mean i'll watch you have a
borderline panic attack uh to pick the
subject of the you know yeah i don't
think you're ready to take on a sweet
16. okay i mean i've watched you
deliberate
am i wrong oh no no you're all right all
right fair enough uh we're on the same
page i'm just saying we should we can
definitely keep the theme up
i'm saying i'm open to it worst case
scenario it's a themed lightning round
okay
uh next week will be another halloween
episode but non-food related we don't
want to give away too much but it's a
pretty cool directly halloween related
episode right
food yeah
um but here we are well why don't we
tease it why can't we tease it
why would it be a surprise they're going
to see the thumbnail next week it's not
going to be a surprise
we could let them we could let them stew
so we could met the marinade
what about that we give him a seven day
runway to marinate the pole
all right
what do you think
i it's making me nervous right now it's
making me nervous right now why they're
going to see the poll first of all today
when you post it and we record the
episode
right
i don't know that you you teased it it's
a halloween themed episode next week
like it's fun the mystery is always
better is it not
i just love that you guys even argue
about this
what do you think
the poll comes out in 20 minutes
whatever you guys want to do yeah i
think we just tell them let them get
excited
because because not everybody that's
voting on twitter today is seeing it
today right so a lot of times people
will be like you know
let them more girl weak about it and see
where we met up all right
next week's battle will be
halloween as an adult
or halloween
as a dead person
as a child kid halloween versus adult
halloween
next week coming at you that is your
idea and i think it's gangbusters and it
is the fan i was just giving you crap
about the uh deliberating over ideas
that is the fastest i've ever seen you
go yeah let's do that
wow that's such good because i didn't
know what i would take it first
uh neither of us know yet yeah we
haven't really just i've i've
flip-flopped in my head i know so have i
but
two worthy opponents that i feel
passionately about on both sides so
speaking of worthy opponent
what were reese's originally called they
were called penny cups as in nickel and
dime the first peanut butter cup a
peanut butter and chocolate confection
was launched in 1928 by the hb reese
candy company the official product name
was actually penny cups because the cost
was one cent at the time in nineteen
sixteen it was a lot that's imagine
getting a hundred peanut butter cups for
a buck
forget about a long distance
a lot for 1928. well there's no there's
no lesser there's no lesser amount of
maybe you get like five for a penny five
for a penny i don't know yeah is it what
weren't holmes like seven cents
i just read that sugar was for rich
people back in the day oh wow also maybe
this was a
and uh you know an amenity okay all
right um in 1963 the hershey company
purchased the hb reese candy company
from hb reese's sons how do you like
that so the guy
hershey's been owning reese's for 60
years can i ask you a question uh what
does the hb stand for in h.b reese
that's just for my own curiosity he's
not that has much to do with this battle
hb i'm going to say herbert brown reese
that's my guess harry burnett damn
harry brunette rhys all right peanut m
ms uh what do we got here peanut m ms
came out in 1954. they're that old i
didn't know that
nowadays m ms are available in
everything from dark chocolate to
pretzel varieties and in sizes that
range from mega to mini much like the
peanut butter cup
but the first spin-off was the tried and
true
eminem developed by mars less than 15
years after the original candies or the
peanut m excuse me uh 15 years after the
original candies began rolling off the
production line they were only available
in tan at first that's disgusting wow uh
then in 1916
came the colors fun fact mars was
actually allergic to peanuts so he never
got to taste his creation how about that
is it his is he the first person to put
him together
his
peanut butter and chocolate no nuts and
chocolate
well i mean peanut butter and chocolate
i feel like it's a good peanut butter
the way they call it his creation though
it's like he was breaking ground
he they're just saying his product that
he made his own his own thing that's
actually a fair point anyone with
allergies doesn't like this episode at
all oh wow do it all right sorry peanut
guys kids so the people with allergies
uh watch this episode like you don't
have one
and guess which one you like you would
might want more yeah you might want
what's more delicious to you
just a just a little peanut just a
little peanut nugget
that you know it's really the cheapest
nut and also you want you want the
smooth cream butter of that nut
i also
also well the fact that you're even
trying to call what is in the middle of
a peanut butter cup peanut butter is
insane well certainly it is that's like
calling you know you know
chicken mcnugget chicken
braces even has its own peanut butter
spreadable peanut butter in stores babe
oh yeah i know
now that that i would say is a lot
closer to real peanut butter but but you
would agree that in a battle of eminem
versus peanut m m peanut eminem beats
despite people's allergies if you put a
peanut m m versus an m m poll online do
you think peanut m m would win despite
peanut allergies
i do think it would win still yes
because i think peanut allergies
though
you know fairly common i don't think
that they are far into my majority of
people i think it's a less common thing
so
uh but uh i just tell you i know i just
contradicted myself but you know what i
mean you know yeah if we have a
tournament with sweet 16 i think eminem
and peanut m m have to be in there
together i think maybe in round one they
face each other i mean i wouldn't cross
the street for a regular eminem it's a
hershey's kiss to me it's a waste of
time it's a waste of money i agree the
regular eminem
leaves something to be desired but then
again sometimes when you're not
expecting to have m ms and you have them
they're they're they're better than fine
and you know what i like to do when are
you not expecting to have them and you
have them
uh you know
whenever that happens
when does that happen
so many peanut butter cups each year
reese's makes so many peanut butter cups
each year that it could feed
one cup
to every person in the usa europe
australia japan china africa and india
with its annual production
jesus christ
that's
how could that be so
just billions how many of these things
are people eating i mean they said india
so it's got to be billions
uh just to relate to to the people at
home with a peanut allergy i also can no
longer eat either of these candies why
because of my uh dairy weird thing that
i have now
and one of the things that sets it off
over everything besides regular old milk
is
candy like chocolate candy for some
reason really sets it off and i have
tried to revisit both the peanut butter
m m i mean the peanut m m and the
reese's peanut butter cup many times and
i can't do it anymore but i do re i do
have a fond recollection of the flavor
of both of these and i am ready to fight
reese's peanut butter cups two great
tastes that tastes great together and
how do you eat a reese's and there's no
wrong way to eat a reese's i love that
good luck with that my friend those
things are iconic i love that the pop-up
ad on the reese's peanut butter cup fan
page is uh the sopranos movie
that features flagrant racism
and then murder
that could be based on me so
[Laughter]
that's where he clicks
uh all right let's get into this battle
you ready
i am ready
oh big time they wanted on a shirt yeah
big time yeah let's go to this at the
comments we'll put it on a shirt we got
designs in already we got it yeah we
gotta do it ready yeah
no no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you
v-a-t-t-l-e buds
wild this is wild we're middle-aged
it's wild it's wild let me tell you now
why
people love it i know
it props to you it's crazier in person
everyone
shout outs
i can't believe no matter what happens i
love you took off like a phoenix rising
i gotta be out of shape i can't believe
it did either i think a lot of it had to
do with how tickled you and pimp were by
which i also didn't expect i didn't
think you guys were going to laugh at
all when i introduced you
you thought of that that was born out of
you really feeling down about and then
the fact that you told me you were
walking around chanting it to yourself
for a week i wasn't cheating it out loud
it was just in my head for a week fine
still very funny the wording in my head
yeah because there were different
wordings but the uh the uh but
i was just gonna do my first hey babes
uh shout outs to the chance
yeah shout out shout out chance
gregorian or otherwise yeah uh here's
the thing this is why i'm gonna say that
my candy i'd rather have my peanut m ms
dropped in my halloween bag than your
reese's peanut butter cup
there's
when you're a kid
there's the excitement of the excess
that you get with halloween with candy
and i think that that excitement about
excess
carries over into adulthood when it
comes to any sort of food product nobody
likes getting a skimpy plate nobody
likes getting a small amount of
something we can all pretend that it's
classy or whatever but it sucks
so
you get a bag of peanut m ms it's
exactly that it's a bag of something
there's such an enjoyment to a bag of
something
there's a rationing that can happen
that the peanut butter cup
does not allow for
every peanut butter cup i've ever had
regular size or mini whole thing goes in
my mouth at once because oh no the whole
the whole size is i bite no i put the
whole thing in my mouth what are you
what is wrong with you
it's not that big
yeah but it's not about fitting it in
your mouth it's perfect for two or three
bites i've never i've also never had one
that isn't actively melting
ever what do you what they come it comes
in the paper wrapping inside there's an
extra sheath of wrapping around the cup
the wrapping is around the bottom part
it doesn't protect your fingers from the
top part because there's no way to hold
it otherwise you gotta hold it like this
how do you hold it like that on the
sides no but as long as you're not
holding in your hand for a long amount
of time you're not really getting
melting everywhere i gotta say i am
hard-pressed to remember a time i wasn't
eating reese's peanut butter cups and
there was not like a
i did not feel like i was against the
clock fixture mike's thing please
i don't feel like that however with a
lot of other candies but regis peanut
butter cups for some reason i feel like
they are going down from the second you
take that thing out of the out of the
no it's it is a really nice delicate
supple chocolate coating on top there
that if you put your finger on you get a
fingerprint like i get that
does react right away to heat that's not
going to affect the way the thing tastes
in my mouth it's a taste explosion no no
the taste is the same i'm saying though
i put it all in my mouth at once for the
reason that it's it's fading away i like
peanut butter uh peanut m ms okay
they're my favorite m m i actually have
a candy machine downstairs filled with
them i know because i can't put in
peanut butter cups because they don't
work in the machine well they would melt
no
they were very first my very first love
affair with the candy my very first one
was reese's peanut butter cups the first
time that my mouth tasted a peanut
butter cup i said i dare maybe peanut
butter and jelly is the only better one
two combination i've ever seen in my
life
i also like chocolate and pretzels
but uh chocolate pudding is great but
peanut
peanut
and chocolate and a candy shell is
pretty good but that peanut butter
with chocolate
is uh
it's a combination i gotta be honest i
don't even think uh i think reese's
peanut butter cups could even beat
kitkat or snickers in a battle snickers
has peanuts in it already you're getting
bold on that one
uh you're getting bold on that also you
could you could have access if you buy a
package of mini cups
you could treat them a little bit like
an m m i love having mini cups the mini
cups are a pizza i like them better i
take them all out in one shot i pop them
in my mouth i can't tell you why the
mini cups suck they don't taste as good
there's something that happens in the in
the configuration and construction of
those mini cups they do not carry the
same flavor as the large cup and the
mini cups always to me taste as if
they're slightly going bad like that
they've been in the cupboard just a
little too long the big cups different
story you keep your reese's cups in your
cupboard
who are you in the cupboard like they
were up there for too long but here's my
point if i if you if i blindfolded you
and you open your mouth and i put in a
mini or a piece of a hole you're going
to be like one of these things 100
come on joe 100 come on different
consistency different texture different
flavor
flavor is the same i'm telling you this
one you bring up one of the things i
love about the peanut butter cup it's a
different sugar that rigid outer ring
that has a little snap to it leaving the
center soft it's almost like a chocolate
peanut butter pie
i swear to god for like a smurf i can
also tell you this right it's like
you're eating two little pies the middle
is soft and breaks very easily but when
you snap around the edge that like that
hardened like uh and like a reinforced
chocolate rigid ring around the edge i
love eating that it's very good it snaps
and then you feel the rigidity
in your mouth against against the
smoothness of the cream
peanut butter and it makes for a very
nice fake chocolate which is a candy
shell made out of red dye number one
through 100. you think you're you think
your thing's not dyed
you think nothing in that peanut butter
cup has died you think it's just
staining those exact colors all the time
without ever failing ever
i don't know do they put dye in
chocolate and peanut butter
i mean sure unnatural colors i'm sure
reese's peanut butter cups have died in
chocolate in them
or diet we could find out in their
chocolate peanut butter
red eminem's disappeared for a decade in
the early 70s a russian study came out
linking red food dye to these are the
people that
these are the people that stole our
election by the way
this is this is who we're listening to
now the russians
subsequent testing never proved the
ingredients to be dangerous but in 1976
shout out by centennial the food and
drug administration airing airing on the
side of caution decided to ban its use
america can i give you a little trip
first peanut uh first eminem colors that
you recall i'm thinking they're the
first ever but
i always remember i know they said they
were all possible remember green orange
and yellow first
yes and brown that's it that's all it
was and light brown yeah i bet your
light brown was the tan they were
referring to that they were all the same
colors brown always bugged me because it
was redundant light brown bugged me too
yeah it was red i felt like it wasn't
making an effort at all
do i've come to the conclusion today
that reese's minis tastes like but whole
wait what
oh
they taste
they spelled buffalo wrong they they
they have the two real words b-u-t and
h-o-l-e but
i came to the conclusion today that
reese's minis tastes like butthole
compared to the regular cups i mean the
minis are all right but the regular cups
are the best chocolate to ever been
created the real wordsmith here with
this post
you're going to believe the person that
spelled butthole two words but
space hr here's the thing i'll give you
another i'll give you another point to
why the
the mini cups are different the mini
cups
never feel like they're melting
the big cups do but but there is a
different there's something different
about those mini cups
what i just love when you start to get
serious
there's something i never liked those as
a kid i never liked the mini topic
though i'm really battling for the
original wreath cup and anything
anything
as long as i'm not deviating from the
taste the minis i i i think would be
included here when but it doesn't matter
i'm back
when a lady would throw the mini cups
into my bag okay yeah at halloween and i
say lady i say lady only because i come
from a time where men got drunk and
women had emotions and that was it the
men were never handing candy out at the
doors you grew up in the 60s yeah the
women were the 80s but the women were
the nurturers that did nice things and
the men were
real pricks a lot of the times yeah but
anyway
but you're talking about but in
halloween you only get a fun sized bag
when they threw the fun size before it
was called that by the way when they
threw mini cups into my bag versus the
big ones
i was like these are going to mom these
ones i had candy i'd separated be like
my mom
listen to this sociopath
what child gets a fist full of reese's
mini cups thrown in their bag looks in
it and goes these are going straight to
my mother yeah yeah what kid does that
you didn't separate your candy from the
stuff you were willing
to give away i'll give you my halloween
routine me and my sister would come home
we'd have we'd buy
plastic halloween bags
i didn't really mess with the plastic
pumpkin and i never really just used a
shot although sometimes i have to use a
shopping bag but we bought they sold
them and they had like the plastic
handles that would snap together so they
would hold it tight which always ripped
once you really got
up there you ever get to a second bag on
halloween
you've gotten to a second bag yeah four
bags you got into four bags i live in
flushing
what does that mean there's so many
people so many wow so you could just do
you could just there's density oh yeah
you're just firing off apartment
buildings are a big score oh you're
saying you go one
one floor and you ring every single bell
and then they all come and you just do a
round robin well these are the multi
homes out in queens so you getting like
five families two in the front two in
the back
yeah i lived in the suburbs i got one
bag but i would go out with a my bag was
a pillow case
and it would be pretty damn full that is
a large bed yeah but it it feels like
we're ergonomically a sound why because
that you got to just grab a fistful of
linen and when that bag gets heavier
like don't you want handles
i didn't need handles i put it over my
shoulder like a hobo you look like a
halloween santa yeah
no no we all did pillowcases
also i wouldn't want to the thing i
sleep on i wouldn't want to be dragging
it around and mom would give me a pill
because she didn't care about anymore
and then we'd throw it away after the
pillowcases can hear us
i feel the pillowcase i came but dude i
lived in the suburbs there were there
were multiple suburbs next to each other
developments rather so it was huge so
what i would do first we come in we come
in me and my sister here i sit over here
she's over there we dump both bags we
then parse out and leave all of our
things together so i'll put all
chocolates here and then the chocolate
section i'll put all the peanut m's all
the reese's and the same thing so i
would group everything i would go ahead
write it write it right ahead and
segregate my candies
and then you could take stock of what
you had and we would do trades but never
would i look at something that entered
my bag and being like that's going
straight to my mother especially when
it's a premium chocolate confetti i
didn't have any siblings
right so i separated my candy in the in
what i was what i wanted and what i was
willing to give away to barter for
things
so you and i knew my mom would like
something your mother would give you
goods and services in exchange no but
i'd get on her good side by giving her
some of my candy all right
separately
[ __ ] i didn't want couldn't she just
take it
she wouldn't do that why would she take
it i went out there and earned it
because she's the boss yeah of course
she could take it she just didn't she
didn't do that so then why do you think
giving it to her would get her on your
good side i would just what do you want
from me sal i don't understand what
you're even asking me right now
let me keep all my friend i'm asking
questions about it let me keep all my
candy she didn't force herself into
taking any of it but i would give her
some because i loved my mom
but i would only give her the stuff i
didn't want no no there you have it you
would give it to her because you love
her say that
well yeah really you said you gave it to
her with ill motivation no i'd give it
to her i'd give her the stuff i didn't
want to get points but i wasn't really
getting rid of anything that mattered to
me where did the points cash in
tell me the scenario you look like a
nice kid to your mom
so it's a front
what do you mean i don't know what kind
you do you're bringing in conversational
behavior with your mother you're putting
up she's like this is the joe jurors i
want her to know she doesn't know that
joe duro's i am upstairs in my room i
don't know what kind of unconditional uh
compassion household you came out of
but my mom and me
[Laughter]
so sometimes i had to get credit in the
bag
before i screwed up again the next week
my i could picture you like literally
with like under a zombie like ma you see
that 100 grain on the table it's for you
100 grand you're out of your mind for
you you're out of your mind i want to
brush my teeth like giving up a hundred
grand no way
you're kidding me no i said you're out
of your mind was if you think i was
giving up a hundred grand and i said
you're kidding hundred grand's a great
candy bar a hundred grand wouldn't be on
this earth if it wasn't for halloween
the fun size is halloween is carrying
the hundred grand on its back who buys a
full-size hundred grand we might have
even spoken about this no doesn't
underground come in two pieces in the
thing you're a guy who takes the reese's
cups and gives them to your mom
give away a hundred grand the mini cups
100 grand was around when they were like
extra extra read all about it 200
grand's a great bar uh i'll tell you
what else we're in that pile
butterfinger every time
that you didn't want no yeah tell you
what oh i like a butterfly often i i'd
often throw uh uh
if i got a ju stuck with a juji fruit
i'd slide those over
oh yeah juji fruits i never understood
them
i never understood the appeal i couldn't
imagine spending money on juji at the
counter
peloton
[Music]
can i tell you something i uh used to
live in a building that had a gym in it
and uh
you think that's the dream right like
you know you gotta build a gym in your
own building you don't have to give me a
car building with a pizzeria sure sure
but you got a gym in the you don't have
to get in your car i still didn't go
down there
i still do that right and and and i
thought that was the easiest thing to do
but i got a peloton
now the peloton is in that room right
there i'm looking at it and now all i
have to do is get out of bed and walk 10
steps and get on a bicycle and i join a
high energy class with a really cool
instructor sometimes i drive and i see
landscape and it's just the coolest
thing it's this huge tv screen and it
just makes it you can tell you're not a
fitness guru because you referred to
riding a bike as drive
uh but in any case
i've got thousands of cardio and
strength classes for you to take
advantage of to take as little as 15
minutes i love that sometimes when
things get overwhelming you know taking
care of yourself is tough because you've
got to be on the go and that's what
peloton is here to help you do
uh and there's never been a better
moment to commit to your fitness goals
because original the original peloton
bike is now 400 less yeah and as soon as
i get busy the first thing i do is
sacrifice the exercising i know right
but when it's right there it's right in
front of you i mean if you have 20
minutes a day it's you're getting that
word you enjoyed it yeah you are revving
up
i've been liking it um my ass i got my
ass isn't finally getting used to it
okay because you know you know it's a
it's a it's a bicycle
and uh it's not a lazy boy recliner if i
may so my ass had to make the adjustment
from a a couch
to a bicycle but now after just a couple
of weeks i'm starting to love it well i
like that they uh you know they have
like
you kind of get a little extra
encouragement from the structured
workouts and you know some of it makes
you kind of laugh and put you in a good
mood and the instructors are fun and
funny and i think that's really great i
like that there's artist collaborations
uh and instructor curated playlists i
love all that stuff that there's game
changing confusion eo plus a strength
class like i think you know this is this
is it's good stuff there's a reason
everybody talks about it i finally got
it i get what the hype is about and of
course uh we gotta give you this
experience motivation like never before
with the peloton bike now four hundred
dollars less go to one
peloton.com to learn more that's spell
it out not the number one but that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n dot-com to check out
more about the pellets so there's
essentials in life i call them everyday
essentials that you want to give a
little extra care and attention to you
know i get that maybe it's your
groceries maybe it's the shoes you wear
shoes are big you stand on your your
feet half your life you're running them
sometimes you know two thirds you know
the tires on your car because you drive
that car every day i'm gonna throw
sheets
into this category uh if you know me and
i'm not even i'm not even being
facetious i say you spend your money on
experiences
shoes and bedding yes you spend a third
of your life sleeping you spend that
money on betting trust i agree i agree
don't cut corners when it comes to
betting a good night's dress is what's
important and i tell you what i like to
put on my sleep number bed yeah sheets
by a little company called bowling
branch bowl and branch signature
that's a little bit of a tongue twister
right there bowling branches signature
sheep bowling branches signature sheets
feel so soft and light you'll forget
you're not actually sleeping on a cloud
they are really really great uh they are
up there right now for me i love them uh
let me see here uh
i mean look i've bought this is my
problem what i always what i like about
bowling bridge is you get the great
sheets and it's a price that's not gonna
bother you for spending it you know what
i mean it's it's in a reasonable it's a
reason i tried to buy sheets off online
like i had good reviews dude they were
terrible i know i've done that i've done
that and i'm like why do people lie i've
cut corners and bought
less expensive sheets because i thought
you know these will
you know the
how much better could the more expensive
i've been wrong every time and what did
you do with bowling branch you got like
what color or something like what what
finish i went with i went with a with a
grayish white i forget the name of the
the color that it was but just a nice a
nice neutral comfortable gray they're
wonderful sustainable sustainable
quality yeah the quality is unbeatable
fair price at a fair price yes which is
very important you know uh their
signature hem sheets
and their best sellers for a reason
buttery soft lightweight organic cotton
all right uh they're not too hot not too
cool that's big for me too oh my gosh my
number one most hated thing yeah so i
run hot at night and they're made at a
higher standard 100 organic cotton
ethical production thoughtful attention
to every detail there's nothing worse
than fitted sheets that don't fit that's
true it goes from twin to california
king experience the best sheets you've
ever felt at bowl and branch dot com get
15
off your first set of sheets when you
use promo code taste buds at checkout
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
b-r-a-n-c-h dot com promo code taste
buds
but
a peanut m m you're nuts that was going
in my lunch bag is that a is that a pun
yes i do have one question what was your
best childhood costume
uh wait should we stay there for next
week
um if you will well i'll actually
probably have to give it something
that's a little more in line with next
week
yeah i love it yeah i love it i do love
it i already know the answer okay oh wow
i gotta i gotta put some too i have a
tie answer
i hope i can remember that next week
the uh here's the thing
peanut m ms you get a bag of those
that's what you're throwing that's going
into my lunch that i'm bringing to
school for the next year
what a great dessert as a kid the other
thing is gone too quickly
maybe let's say you do take bites out of
your reese's cup what are you getting
two bites
two bites not as a child bro but even
now
even now i could do a reese's cup and
i'll do a reese's cup and i usually do
it in two but i'll do it in three if i
feel if i'm feeling like fun about it
like if i want to ration it but you got
to be look dude look reese's cups were
the first candy that i ever
thought king size was necessary i don't
mean king size like the big cups i mean
when they came out with the king-sized
pack that was four cups yeah i was like
it's about time i'm getting a decent
sized serving of these things yeah but
but babe we're not arguing portion
control within the packaging i'm arguing
the cup you can buy in a two pack or a
four pack one shoe halloween he only got
a single pack but one shouldn't negate
the other i'm talking about why the
reese's cup is better than the peanut m
not because it can go and to your point
you said that the peanut m m comes in
excess you love it it comes in a bag but
really the peanut butter if we're
talking halloween you're really getting
snack size and you know that's only like
what peanut m is like five not that much
also isn't it something better than a
little fun size they're like we're gonna
give you a third less but we'll call the
[ __ ] that's somebody's bit that's why i
didn't say that earlier is it really
yeah oh i hope it's something good
it's a bit it's like somebody has a bit
about that like the ripper well i'm not
doing a bit about it but no but that's
it about it because it's crunched
like it's the biggest hustle like they
called it fun-sized yeah yeah it's true
though yeah uh what do we got here in
1968
is this reese's
i think this is this is just in general
okay
uh in 1968 new candies were launched
that were slightly larger than junior
ones but still smaller than mars
traditionally sized bars the company
used fund sizes to describe this
category of suites all right so fun size
was developed by mars
mars doesn't own either of these
companies hershey owns reese's does
marzo and m m's
i'll have to look it up but this is cool
for m m's
one another surprising fact about m ms
in the beginning it was the only avail
only available to the military the tubes
of chocolate were included in soldiers
rations and were ideal as they didn't
melt
and could be
resealed it wasn't until later
that civilians could get their hands on
them once again my team is for the good
of the united states of america and the
working man
look at the colors from the look at
those colors look at those different
colors wow those are like pastels those
like 1970s colors
49. oh the ammonites first came oh so we
were wrong check this out the eminem's
first came in six colors brown yellow
orange red green and violet
violet wow
you remember the eminem that famous
eminem commercial which i think we
probably talked about already but the
baseball one where uh there's two kids
playing little league and they're giving
him the m m's and he goes you want some
m m's maybe i'm messing it up a little
bit but he goes he goes
he goes with the uh he goes
he goes uh
the brown is a single with the yellow if
i eat a yellow i hit a double
i eat the orange is a triple and with
the green ones i take the ball downtown
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
eminem baseball little league baseball
commercial by the way by the way
but i also that after that commercial in
my life to this day as a 40 something
year old man
i look at green m m's as the most
powerful eminem and i'm gl and while
pimp sets this works whoever did that
great marketing while pimp sets this up
i'm glad you brought up commercials i'm
glad you brought up commercials yeah you
want to talk commercials you want to
talk commercials
babe i'm all over you with commercials
please you go to the movies they're
showing my guys on the screen dude
they're showing eminem's commercials in
the theater well that's because the
the the the m m's themselves became
anamorphic
and anthropology
right personalized brings up another
good point once somebody saw reese's
peanut butter cups in a movie theater
old ever ever every movie almost never
because we're not single it's not every
single no longevity to that snack every
movie theater has no no no no no no no
gonna start making things up
you're wrong
what time are we at pimp we're at about
30 minutes 30 minutes is when joe starts
making things up
you're very wrong i didn't know this did
you realize
uh marge denies that the latter's
inspiration was hershey's reese's pieces
which shot to fame after appearing at
spielberg's e.t
uh you know that right they offered him
m m's first and eminem said no to e.t
and spielberg that's why it's reese's
pieces well the ever popular m m's
peanut were launched in 54.
and m m's peanut butter they're saying
the peanut butter candies were not a
reaction to reese's pieces right they
don't taste the same at
all and in fact actually reece's pieces
are way better than peanut butter i
disagree i think reese's pieces are [ __ ]
i i think they're [ __ ] i think they i
don't think they taste good i don't oh
here's your
batting commercial is totally awesome
what's your secret eminem i hit singles
when i ate the brown ones that was with
yellows orange triples and with the
green ones i take the ball downtown
[Music]
that's stephen no it's not yes it is no
it is not i promise you it's stephen
door because you're looking at him
because you recall now that he we're to
google it and i will bet you money right
now you have to put money on it right
now your money on it right now money on
it wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
pim can i see the face of the child one
more time so i can i could
are you you really think that's stephen
dorff i don't know that what kind of
weird hold on pause that what kind of
weird
mechanics do you have going on in your
brain where you're picking off a 50 year
old actor as a six-year-old child after
i win the bet i will explain you should
work for the police department after i
win the bet i will explain you're over
here closing unsolved mysteries after i
win the bet i will explain that is
steven dorf
look at that eminem's bag rewind that m
m's bag
look at how perfectly [ __ ] that was
like when they close up on it yeah look
at that thing it's a monstrosity yeah
that's how it looks
well maybe it looks like that back then
it just got cheaper i don't know and he
gives him a triple he goes i need the
home runs to myself steven dorff i
understand that it looks like stephen
dorff so you want to put your money
where your mouth is i understand that
according to his age and this being on
85 that could be around the age that
stephen dorf was would you like to put
your money where your mouth is or no
let's make it interesting let's make it
interesting
you tell me let's see how confident
you're feeling 20 bucks is that like a
fail thing yeah i say it's not stephen
dorff it's steven dorff wait hold on
hold on look at me look at me look at me
promise me that you didn't remember that
you already knew this i didn't know this
so you're going based on this commercial
in the last five seconds when i win i'll
tell you why okay i also don't know who
i'm looking for who the
he said hell is stephen
actor who um
was in blade and a lot of other things
and then was in the e-cigarette i don't
know why but he was like blue cigarettes
which he later had beef with
i don't know pip you had it stephen
dwarf eminem commercial
yeah but does that prove that he's
hold on slow down
i don't see anything babe
oh man i thought you were waiting by the
way is dwarf with 1b by the way no it
won't be on imdb
no no
commercials i will ask let's ask the
fans let's ask the listeners
he
all right i'll tell you what to do now
put in stephen
m commercial no no results okay hold on
a second
pimp
put in stephen dwarf
the gate
and pull up a picture of him from that
movie
oh here we go with this sleuthing shot
you're going to say one
implies second
that's him
in a horror movie one of my faves
starring steven dwarf that's the kid in
the goddamn m m's commercial we just saw
oh oh well i mean that looks like the
kid
but you need to prove it to me well i
mean that's him pimp don't you think
that's right
what is the gate i feel like i know the
gate it's a great horror movie where
they open a gate to hell in their
backyard by accident it's a lot of fun
oh that old thing
hmm i don't know why don't you go to
stephen dorff's i uh
wikipedia great i got the hiccups it's
not pissed i don't put commercials on
imdb i've because i've looked before but
why wouldn't it come up stephen dorff
eminem because maybe nobody knows he's
in the commercial i didn't know that
till just now who the hell remembers
this commercial besides you and three
other people you know what i mean i mean
no that was a famous commercial that
affected me finally
did you know this i could be driving did
you know this did you know jack black
was in a pitfall commercial
the game yes
no
not many people do i like stuff like
that yeah i'd love to go through a whole
rabbit hole of watching people wait
before that time pimp his pimp is all
over the place right now he's he's
overloading over here mrs pieces were
relatively weird
we want to go deep jack black let's do
it no no no
no no no but wait a second no i want you
to go side by side
in the eminem commercial and and steven
dorff from the from the gate maybe click
on his wiki
it might be like he's famously known for
sorry all right
joe let me ask you this because i want
to talk about harry's and harry's
morning routine have you looked in the
mirror recently because i don't think
yeah i try to
i gotta be honest like really looking
forward to try to avoid it at all yeah
that be that beard you grow out over
this last year was the hot new thing you
didn't grow a beard over a pandemic
right i did not i will tell you i know
that my beard needs eventually this
thing's got to come off and in fact i'm
holding on to nothing in fact i will
tell you this one of the reasons i
didn't grow a beard is also one of the
reasons why i love harry's and harry's
product i have a very very coarse beard
uh when it gets to a certain length it
becomes very irritating therefore when i
shave i need an extremely close shave
that creates a smooth surface on the
skin it is very hard for me to come by
i've tried every razor out there where
it's like we added nine more plays
and i have to say
and also every time they add a blade the
price goes up so harry's
they're doing high quality long lasting
blades
durable weighted handles that make for a
close comfortable shave and dare we say
enjoyable you do dare say harry and i'll
tell you what i'm taking that dare
because it is enjoyable it's one of the
it might be the only razor i'm not just
saying this it might be the only reason
i've ever used where when i shave with
it
it feels like a relief is happening
like i feel a relief
i'm like something's going away i'm
getting rid of this thing that i don't
want on my face exercise your demons
with harry's razors yeah refill blades
thought as low as two bucks that's an
easy decision you just told her exactly
how they charge all that money um
harry's new uh new harry's customers get
uh their starter set which includes a
five blade razor weighted handle foaming
shave gel with addle and a travel cover
it's a thirteen dollar value you guys
get it for three bucks that is never
been a better time to try harry's go to
harrys.com taste buds to get their
starter set for just three beans it's uh
bucks it's 100 satisfaction guaranteed
so you've got nothing to lose go to
harrys.com tastebuds right now to get
this special offer that's h-a-r-r-y-s
dot com slash taste buds
better help this podcast is sponsored by
better help one of my favorite sponsors
not that i'm choosing favorites here but
i am a little bit because i think that
betterhelp is really doing something
truly wonderful for people that need it
more than ever right now yeah it's
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving goals uh what you do is you
contact them they assess your needs and
they match you with a licensed
professional therapist that could happen
in under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not even self-help it's just
professional counsel counseling and it's
done securely online uh this is
revolutionary this kind of thing there's
a broad range of experts that may not
normally have been available in your
areas they can service clients worldwide
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
anytime you get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video sessions phone sessions you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room that that was always like
when i went to
like a therap like the old school way of
therapy that always bothered me was like
you you had to make sure you carved out
a part of your day for it which can be
hard enough if you have a schedule of
any kind and then you got to get there
there's travel time which adds to it and
then you're sitting in the waiting room
and then sometimes the other session is
running late you could literally just
plop down in your living room the fact
that you can do this from home and but
by the way you're having a day where you
don't feel like getting out of your
pajamas and you're having a hard time
motivating and you can get right on the
screen with your sponsors when i'm stuck
in the house is when i want to talk to
you and say i'm having this kind of day
look at me i mean i just think i think
doing it from your home makes it
infinitely a better sense go to the
betterhelp.com website and read the
reviews that'll that'll cue you in as to
how much people are benefiting from this
uh betterhelp.com tastebuds today visit
and and uh that's help not health better
help join over a million people who've
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
special offer for taste buds listeners
again 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
taste buds b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash taste buds
or not famously but
wait what oh you're doing it side by
side okay
all right
oh that looks like him come on shout be
a man of your honor that's him that
looks like he's got that those same eyes
that's him dude yeah hold on hold on let
me think let me picture that kid's
sucking wait go down oh it's the
comments
on a blue cigarette the comments will
say it i bet
maybe they will oh wow nobody's picking
up on this i mean he's not let's be
honest steven dorff also died
stephen
jessica's one
so now it's not good enough a person
commenting with no likes
the thing's got six comments on it and
one of them is stephen dwarf is the
white it has 58 000 views though that's
not a lot of views let's go to this it
looks like him it looks like him let's
just go to the wiki man
early life career let's hit it
all right he was raised in los angeles
acting child appearing in commercials
for kraft and mattel it's him well i
mean that wasn't craftable mattel but
he's it's saying he some of the notable
commercial comp companies or companies
he did
no that's reese witherspoon
i i mean if you don't pay this that
that's that's come on dude you're better
than this
go back go back go back go back
a little bit lower
no
god darn it oh
all right
let me do it side by side again
i'll pay you the money all right thank
you 20
by the way that reminds me i never got
my gift card to joey rose's so in the
last bet you lost you cannot it's yours
oh i was holding i was holding my 20
until pimp is paid in full i'm with
holding my twitter one second
it's yours what do you mean i am your
gift card it's on the bottom
it's on the bottom
i wonder if my neighbors hear me go i'm
withholding payment until the pimp is
paid in full
i mean
that doesn't sound good the the the the
scrutiny you just put that through whoop
legal tender was on the line
can i just hear how he speaks to because
also play and then play i would have
never pegged this kid and then play a
clip from the gate sure i would have
never pegged this kid to grow up and be
an actor that's taken seriously because
his his point of view on this on both of
these lines is hysterical well really
it's the writer but like he's doing like
a hardcore cell phone listen is he yeah
he's that's where he's putting the bat
over like a microphone
yeah he's doing it let me see it again
can you start from the beginning
oh
i didn't see the bat as the microphone
yeah he's doing like a
that's dwarf again
oh that he did that little thing at the
end now pimp pull up the gate
try to remember the voice what kid what
kid goes magnificent
other than me the line
maybe not the trailer pip just see if
there's a scene you know what i mean
because the trailer might be all like
voice over and stuff
this
this movie this commercial hold on this
commercial also wants us to believe
that in the in the reality of that
commercial stephen dorff ate the orange
eminem went up and hit a triple do you
know a triple is ten times harder to hit
than a home run i don't know that uh i i
don't
i don't know there you're there he was
just yeah if you got wheels on you
you're lucky you get 10 triples in a
year i think i don't know that they
really wanted us to believe that but i
hear you
ready well what happens i'd like to see
what happens next
you'll never know i like to that's the
beauty of the marketing campaign they
can't show you that that's a bunch of
[ __ ] right there because kids were
buying those things and they were
striking out
ad nauseam would do do you think it was
designed in any other way
well that's not right
that's not right
a lot of little league teams went down
in flames that yeah i mean you know i
had action figures that claimed to have
something called kung fu grip to this
day i don't know what that was okay
there was no kung fu grip all right here
he is
what are those little things chasing
them it's the monsters that came out of
the gate
even from that little
thing with noise in the background i
could tell it's him
that's ridiculous it's not you know i'm
right i'll pay you the 20. yeah you will
all right all right congratulations on
you win thanks let's go to the phones
all right how many votes we got in so
far we got 13 000 very nice
all right and that's on a refresh two
pimp
okay
13 000 votes uh if someone says i don't
like peanut m ms you shrug it off but if
someone says they don't like reese's
you're checking their white pages
immediately i love it what the hell does
that mean i'm not i'm not sure but i
know the i know what he's inferencing i
don't what i know the inference isn't
that a phone book the white page yeah
yeah
i don't know i don't understand but i
know what he means peanut butter cups my
favorite candy though m m's are pretty
high up there too anything except the
hard candy or worse but all right i hate
when everybody starts going into other
stuff
i shouldn't say please god sal do not be
augering peanut m ms i have too much
respect for you don't worry about it
wally m m's in general peanut crispy
chocolate peanut butter they taste like
little balls of heaven
uh you going uh whoever picked peanut m
ms thinks it's the healthier treat
because of the peanuts you're living in
a fantasy land that didn't even come up
that's i never resist makes my mouth
feel like it's glued shut really should
still rather suffocate and die than
break my teeth on those [ __ ] mm's the
one above it is better reeses reminds me
of soft dog [ __ ]
[Laughter]
taste like easter bunny testicles no
stop it you stop it can you scroll more
just let's get a bunch in there yeah
peanut m ms for me i always got so
excited when i was a kid and i got
peanut items in my halloween bag okay
that was a straightforward peanut butter
cups is the only answer to this question
after one reese's cup it feels like my
mouth was filled with glue and my
stomach is filled with regret all right
peanut butter cuts are my favorite as a
kid but as i get older i can't handle it
without having an upset stomach what is
wrong with these people look i started
having peanut butter i started having an
upset reaction to it you know it's i
don't know peanut m ms are the reason
old people have to wear dentures
you haven't mentioned that you can put
the reese's pieces in the freezer and
have it cold too
yeah but you can do that with m m's too
can you oh let's yeah let me address
this too so i guess you're right you're
right that is a delicacy way to eat i
agree pimp sal didn't you say you were
allergic to peanut butter when you did
this is not happening you asked the lady
for skippy peanut butter smooth and then
instead of a blah blah and thank you
kelly for for addressing i acknowledge
it it was a throwaway joke i made in the
moment for being allergic to peanut
butter because it was funny for the
story it's not actually true that
happens once well i riffed that line and
look kelly got your back he acknowledged
it he just yeah yeah yeah
i've always had a deep hatred for
reese's peanut butter cups because i
love peanut butter but whatever the [ __ ]
is in that thing that's not peanut
butter it's peanut juice mixed with what
the [ __ ] is ipsum
peanut juice
i told you it's not peanut butter in the
middle of that thing dude
oh my god anyone who prefer peter m m's
can go get their hoodie sleeves wet not
sorry reeses
wait what uh i'm not sorry i thought
okay now i get it i'll take a reese's
cup over peanut m m even if someone slit
a razor blade into it
that's something we gotta get into next
week too remember all that oh yeah
that's fear-mongering yeah when you get
a reese's you feel like you won the
lottery when you get a peanut butter m
m's you at least
you like it at least it's not you're
like at least it's top five
i know i know you do feel like you won
the lottery i agree
i agree i just know sal picked peanut m
halloween oh this guy's deep cutting it
i just know south picked peanut m ms as
his candy bar in quotes and sal i love
you my profile pic is you
and i knows to knows but peanut m ms are
the james
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh so he thinks i'm defending peanut and
he's telling me they're no good ah john
guess what good night nurse because i
picked recently john you're looking at
me and him and that is me nose to nose
with him i can't believe i did that
i i don't i would never all right let's
give the win to soft dog [ __ ] sure that
made us laugh really hard
all right cool
uh humble pop wait wait wait wait we got
another instrument oh we gotta announce
our winner let's get a drum roll
we gotta announce our winner you guys
want to summarize your arguments and
this let me just find them
let's announce the winner i think peanut
m ms were giving out more on halloween
and so for me they're less rare as a
treat i think
coming up
excuse us let me let me announce the
winner the winner can wait a second i'm
in the middle of a major point i'm
trying to read the winner
i'm not hearing your argument go with
the winner
follow at
b-e-n-g-a-l-s-c
e
for winning the tweet
for this episode okay now you can go
i was gonna say i think peanut peanut m
ms are given a lot more during halloween
i think they're great but they're giving
a lot more they're less rare to get in
the bag so coming off the heels of what
uh this young lady just said i do think
that when you get a peanut a reese's
peanut butter cup dropped in your bag of
halloween you do feel like it's an
elevated you feel like you hit the candy
lottery uh i disagree i got those single
pack
uh reese's cups all the time but what i
got much more frequently were the mini
rhesus cups i've already established why
i hate those so when i got peanut m ms i
thought that was a treat because i
encountered regular m ms far more
frequently than i did peanut m ms in the
wild
do you have anything
do you have any plugs before we do the
poll yes please hey everybody i'm
finally coming out on tour uh
okay here we go ready come see me all
together savolcano comedy.com i am at
the dania improv in fort lauderdale
november 12th 13th and 14th i am at the
west palm beach improv december 4th and
5th i am at the chevrolet theater if i'm
saying that right i hope i am in boston
uh on december 10th and on saturday
december 11th i am playing the borgata
here in atlantic city new jersey on top
of that from the week of december 26 to
new year's eve i will be at the 26th in
dallas the 27th in san antonio the 23rd
in sugarland texas the 24th sorry i'm
messing all that up 26 27 28. 29th in st
louis missouri uh 30th in columbus ohio
and the 31st on new year's eve in
cincinnati all tickets at
salvoconocomy.com all just got announced
they uh they should be up uh and if not
they'll be up in the coming days more
cities will be announced god bless you
all i will see you there if you don't
come really i'm gonna stop doing all
these podcasts i'm gonna become a
recluse
joey roses the actual bar sandwich shop
is opening within the next few weeks in
fact by the time you see this we might
only be a week or so out uh
174 rivington in new york city on the
new york city's illustrious lower east
side please come hang out with us it's
going to be an amazing time over there
and i will be present
some of the time uh are you coming with
me on any of those dates we're talking
about oh should we we're not talking
about talk about it all fair okay but uh
speaking of dates solo i have solo dates
that i'll be announcing soon but in 2022
i'll be seeing you in buffalo i will be
seeing you in austin i will be seeing
you
in
philly i think hometown your hometown uh
philly yeah philly um
and there's another one that i can't
remember but basically i'm booking out a
string of dates now and i'll be seeing
you guys soon so anyway here we go
with the win
durham october 29th i'm sorry dorm north
carolina october 29th that's in four
days if you know somebody in dorm tag
them in the comments christy d right yes
and that week between christmas is chris
as well okay ready
drumroll
oh
oh oh my god
70.1
for reese's peanut butter cups
i can't believe
this margin of victory i cannot believe
it to
29.9 percent peanut butter eminem's this
wasn't even close and i was i completely
could have told you i thought it was 50
50.
i love this stuff
that's decisive that's that's really
decisive my friend i will tell you this
should reese's peanut butter cups now
face kitkat
let's oh should we just take it to the
sweet 16 tournament let everybody reseed
let's consider yeah yeah how do you feel
thoughts today on this one the show
should be over by now
i still love you babe i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds